Have you heard of Envita Medical Center in Arizona doing a procedure called CIPI chemo immune precision injections?
No, I'm not familiar with that. I am familiar with Envita. We've had three or four people that have gone there, but they went there for insulin-potentiated chemotherapy.
There's more places that are doing insulin-potentiated chemotherapy, but for a while they were the only clinic around that was doing it.
And the people that had gone there were happy with them. I don't remember anybody being unhappy there.
So yeah, they have some new procedure. They legally Arizona is the most open state for alternative practitioners doing different things.
So Arizona law has allowed a lot of things where you can't do that most places.
So yeah, that sounds very interesting. I have a look up that I would look at their clinic for a number of probably since last summer.
So inject chemo in target area and not the whole body for a minute static lesions. That's quite interesting.
Yeah, and again, you're probably not going to find any published studies on that. They can have maybe some of their own data in Arizona that they can self-publish and put out to the people.
But again, like anything, if a cancer, you know, some cancers just don't respond to a chemo and some cancers do.
So everybody's going to be different with their success right with that too.
It's not necessarily the type of cancer. It's how that cancer is growing in that person's body.
It's not just like two people with Don Hodgkins lymphoma can get the same chemo and one responds well and one doesn't respond well at all.
Not that they got injured by the chemo, even it says that it didn't stop the cancer. Well, they have the same cell type. Why wouldn't it stop the cancer? Because everybody's personal chemistry is different.
So that's just the way it is. It's the same way with supplements. One might work perfectly with some one person doesn't work well with another person.
So they're going to have the same issue. So that's the same issue with a lot of people will say most I would should do insulin potential in chemotherapy.
You know, insulin potential in chemotherapy is still chemotherapy. They're just giving you a lower dose, but they have to give you more times. You know, you're going in weekly, typically for that.
So it can have, you know, similar ill effects on your body over time because you're getting many more doses.
But for someone who is so hypersensitive to any types of drugs, many times because the site of Chrome P450 pathways in their body and their liver is impaired, they're just hypersensitive.
The drugs do eat insulin potential in chemotherapy is better. But then the caveat to that is that well, if if that chemotherapy, whether it's a low dose using insulin prior or it's a high dose, going to your oncologist.
If that chemotherapy doesn't work for my cancer, the low dose is going to work for my cancer either. So you just really don't know until you administer it.